ten thousand dollars what the
if you're not careful and paying
attention you could easily spend 35 000
or more over the space of the next
decade on just one program whereas if
you're smart about it from day one you
could save yourself a boatload of money
in today's video we're breaking down the
best and worst architectural software
and which ones you should learn right
now in 2022. not only are we talking
about architectural design software but
we're also going to be looking at the
top seven rendering programs alongside
the top five architectural design
programs let's get started with the top
seven architectural rendering programs
because at the end of the day everybody
loves a good pretty picture first of all
we're going to be starting off with two
of my favorites enscape and twin motion
now enscape and twin motion are much for
muchness they are near identical
programs that can produce near identical
results nonetheless both of these
programs are exceptionally easy to learn
and generate incredible images in the
amount of time it takes to actually
produce one now neither of these
programs are cheap first of all twin
motion is 790 dollars for one off
payments however if you do buy one of
the architectural softwares i'm talking
about you can get it completely free so
stay tuned for that as we break it down
further enscape on the other hand is
58.90 per month if you want a fixed
license on one computer
or it's 109 per month if you want a
floating license so you can transfer it
between all the computers in the office
quickly you realize that enscape will
become significantly more expensive than
twin motion now one of the benefits with
twin motion is to install twin motion
you actually have to download the unreal
engine suite which allows you to also
download unreal engine 5. if you haven't
heard of unreal engine 5 it is a
phenomenal program designed for video
games and cinematics however it is
extremely complicated to learn with a
very steep learning curve on the bright
side unreal engine 5 is completely free
so anybody can go ahead and download it
today install it today and start
learning without spending a single
dollar to take it to the next level
we're really starting to spend a lot of
money now but we're also starting to get
some incredible results first of all we
have lumion and we have 3ds max
lumion is kind of the introduction into
that next series of higher end renders
again on the side of twin motion not
high high-end but it does produce some
phenomenal images whereas 3ds max is the
be-all end-all lumion comes with two
pricing options it is a perpetual
license which means it is yours forever
for two thousand two hundred dollars you
get one third of the capabilities lumion
is actually capable of whereas for four
thousand four hundred dollars you get
the full suite 3ds max on the other hand
may sound cheaper up front but it is not
a perpetual license you have to pay for
it every single year and it costs 2
390
last but not least is cinema 4d and
v-ray both cinema 4d and v-ray basically
work hand-in-hand cinema 4d is as little
as 90 a month whereas v-ray is even
cheaper at 38.90 a month if you stick
around to the end i'll tell you how you
can get most if not all of these
software's either 100 free or
significantly discounted if i was to go
back as a professional architect and
re-learn something from the start back
in my university days i would definitely
have learned 3ds max and potentially
v-ray because both of these can produce
phenomenal results let's move on to the
architectural design software the nuts
and bolts of what all architects need to
understand and what all architecture
students need to learn rapidly you can
spend as little as zero dollars all the
way up to ten thousand dollars by simply
picking different softwares so we're
going to go through my top five and
personal favorites as well as select my
personal winner that i believe is the
most beneficial for all students to
learn moving forward so let's start with
the cheapest and easiest to learn
sketchup is 100 free but it can also
cost you a couple hundred dollars a year
next is brix cad and i have spoken about
bricscad on this channel before rich dad
is basically an up-and-coming bim
software it is something that is
focusing their attention on ai and
artificial intelligence to be able to
actually push the industry further
bricscad is a perpetual license on the
other hand which is a huge win and for
2625 dollars it can be yours forever
third on the list is autocad now
everybody has heard about autocad it is
that program that people have been using
for decades the problem with autocad is
it is very outdated and it isn't
catching up to the rest of the world
that's why autodesk was able to create
revit and basically take that program to
the next level but people are still very
loyal to autocad so that's why it makes
it to this top five list autocad is not
cheap again but it is one of the cheaper
softwares at 2 945 a year it isn't cheap
but it does the job very very well and
it is able to communicate with every
single other program out there by simply
importing dwgs speaking of autocad we
obviously move up to revit now revit is
one of the be all and all software's on
this list it is a bim software it allows
you to model some of the most complex
projects in the world and some of those
projects have actually been modeled on
revit revit has an extremely steep
learning curve but once you've figured
out revit it is a phenomenal program
that you can do anything that you can
imagine it isn't cheap just like every
other architectural software it is
definitely not cheap revit is going to
cost you
3580 per year now in the space of 10
years which is a very very short
architectural career let's be honest
that's almost 36 000
that you're going to spend on just one
program in the office so make sure that
if you're going to learn revit and if
you're thinking about starting your own
office downloading it and paying for it
yourself this is going to be a very
large continuous cost with their base
price continuously going up every year
and some of the biggest architectural
firms in the world even complaining
directly to revit about this so at the
end of the day revit is phenomenal it is
something that is well worth learning
and investing your time into just be
mindful of the steep cost that you're
going to be paying for a lifetime last
but not least on this list is archicad
now if you've been on this channel
before you know i am an arcade user and
i am extremely biased to this software
however archicad is not cheap it is by
far the most expensive upfront capital
cost on this entire list both lists
included so for ten thousand seven
hundred dollars you can get a perpetual
license at archicad today however having
said that if you have that upfront
investment and upfront capital it is
yours forever no more upgrades no more
payments it is yours
archicad will have additional upgrades
same as every other software that you
have to pay for but you don't have to
keep paying for it to use it and you can
continue with that actual system that
you purchase another additional bonus to
archicad if you purchase archicad you
get twin motion for free so instead of
paying an additional 790 like previously
mentioned you're gonna get that 100 free
which is going to drive that overall
cost base down significantly if i was
going to go back in my architectural
career and start again learn a new
software from day one personally it
would again still be archicad 100 hands
down but at the same time it would also
be revit i believe that anybody looking
to learn architectural software for a
professional purpose should learn both
for a personal purpose should pick one
and potentially even pick sketchup just
so you can get some mass free modeling
going and get yourself into that space
rather than committing so much money to
try and work your way into architecture
now like i promised previously all of
these softwares are incredibly expensive
but that doesn't mean you can't download
them today if you're a student in any
way shape or form either university
college or even high school and have
some sort of educational email address
you can sign up to basically every
single one of these for either a free
one year trial or a free perpetual
license which basically allows you to
download install and run any of these
softwares at the same time if you're
looking at buying archicad something
that they don't advertise very often and
you have to actually dig through all of
the information is their archicad start
edition revit also has their revit light
edition
both of these softwares you can get for
50 off their asking price which is
phenomenal and a great way to get a foot
in the door if you're looking to explore
these softwares anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching my name is david thomich i'm a
registered architect here in western
australia and every monday we talk about
architecture and technology on this
channel if you enjoyed this video and
want to see more content like this make
sure you check out the playlist to the
side of me to be able to continue
watching some great content if you
really truly love this video i'd
appreciate it if you smash that
subscribe button down below and like
always i'll see you next monday